jennifer lopez and maluma
steamed up the stage during the 2020
amas
the show went down on sunday night and
despite things looking
a bit different this year due to kovid j
lo and maluma
didn't let a pandemic stop them from
delivering a hot af
world premiere performance of their new
singles
potty and lonely y'all's tvs are about
to melt
yep basically the sexy performance
included
two of the songs the pair co-wrote for
their upcoming rom-com
marry me starring jennifer owen wilson
and of course maluma
j.lo wore a barely there black peekaboo
catsuit
as she sung and writhed around on a lit
table in front of maluma
while the 26 year old singer was dressed
to the nines
in a suit and his signature sunnies
[Music]
the latinx superstars shared their
journey to the stage on social media
yeah mage here we go so we are walking
in this is very different we just did
our colvin test
they swab you and then they take your
temperature
and you put your mask back on and then
you walk in
backstage i love you guys
j.lo not only slayed her performance
covet free she crushed the red carpet
too
[Music]
the 51 year old singer had her signature
j-lo glow
in full effect courtesy of her makeup
artist
mary phillips and her wet like hair was
created
by her go-to hairstylist chris appleton
but the best part was definitely her
balm on
silver plunging two-piece number that
boasted a
thigh high slit which showed off her
toned
legs i still get to dance and you know
perform that keeps you very kind of like
in shape and and uh and youthful as well
jennifer also paired the look with
earrings and rings that
dazzled from luminous diamonds and
mamacita painted on her long white nails
once again proving she is the queen
of the red carpet oh great that was
really hard i'll do that again
oh we know you will
[Music]
you